oh yes I can make you tall this weekend
will become a big boy I don't concern
myself sure I'm just like small I'm a
petite man bite size I thought about
being taller plenty of times when I was
a teenager my mom would be me like home
remedies that person was making taller
there was some element of being taken
less seriously because I was short like
everything I said it's just a silly fun
little thing the little guy said the
only time I feel really short is when
I'm taking a photo with a bunch of tall
guys and then I'm just in the middle and
then they're like here I don't really
feel like bad about the height that I am
but people look at tall people
differently assumed power and confidence
people listen to what you say when
you're short you're perceived as less
sexy being short you're more cute or
adorable
sometimes being short makes me feel like
I have to be submissive to somebody
think of I was taller I would have had a
lot more success with the ladies it
makes you think that anyone who's taller
than you is off-limits for dating I mean
their stats they get paid more
considered more attractive I could sit
here and tell you I don't care and like
most the time I don't but yeah I want to
be taller little nervous maybe I look
weird from down here I'm afraid people
are gonna tell like ha ha ha ha why are
you in the 5 5 & 4 this week I am going
to be 5 8 I'm 5 7 right now and with the
shoe inserts I'm gonna be 5 10 I have 5
7 and 3/4 this week I'm gonna be 5 10
and 3/4 I'll be taller than egg oh this
is the dream I'm five eight and I'll be
511 for a week imagine if you could add
that length other places it's time to
get to-- oh it's just a pad you can take
like how much taller do you want to be
by adding more it's like Legos all of
this is a lot and you just slip it in
only my foot would go here but with the
padding it's here ooh definitely gotta
loosen up these leases surprisingly
comfortable it's like a pillow for heel
oh I feel like a baby giraffe taking his
first step cool to like see a view from
a little higher than I ever have before
aside from like when I'm on a
rollercoaster I feel like I can reach
for the stars and I'll grab
them I hope that I can walk normally
more self-assured I just feel like I
don't give as many shits anymore I'm a
powerful tall man now the world is mine
I don't take these things out you notice
anything different about me
this is milk though your hairs a little
wet you're wearing clown shoes cut
tolerating you're taller yeah I had to
literally bring in the word tall do you
know anything different about me shorter
haircut in the back you know wearing
different clothes I'm three inches
taller oh really
maybe I'm just so short that everyone
just looks tall I didn't want to say but
like I was gonna say you look a lot more
fit and I don't know if it has to do
with the shoes what do you think about
like guys using that I think they should
totally use it I wear them to look
taller too does it make you feel more
confident it does you have this glow
tall person and fit person glow oh
you're tall now what's going on Eugene
you stand up you tiny little man get
over here when you're still talking yeah
are you doing down there watching your
feet yeah understand my head is still
absurdly tiny you're like at all babies
at all baby this is literally so
confident right now that I feel like I'm
losing the feeling in my feet they're
gonna be like blue we are normally about
the same height and now you're taller
than me I don't like cuz everyone's
talking might be can barely in these
shoes I hate them so much
welcome to here I go from here to here
oh we so disappointing for a girl or a
guy on a date who thinks the guy's tall
right yeah goes home and takes off his
shoes and then it's like just baby hurry
what do you see what's in my pants huh
what I love about these is that you
can't tell he's wearing anything inside
this just changed the game
we don't need knee surgery anymore the
Chris was with the stills you look
pretty uncountable like a newborn deer
but standing you look great so 10 to 15
people I know not one of them noticed me
looking taller there was one part where
I was looking over a few people's head
to see someone speaking at the front and
that was kind of nice I tried ducking
down to see what my normal view would be
and I wouldn't have been able to see it
all for the same height no no I'm just
not standing up straight are you in tall
shoes so you like it I do it's so
comfortable and I love
even though no one notices it yeah you
know it I feel like I fell in the world
I mean what do you think cheater cheater
I think you can get away with it there's
no one to tell you're with a girl
whatever I don't think she'll be able to
be like in bed like you're shorter than
I'm fixing a thing because I'm tall
normally I have to stand on my tiptoes
to put the dead batteries away but now
even though no one notices I have to
admit that I I'm starting to like it the
feeling of being tall there's something
that changes the way I'm interacting
with people is different like I've never
been taller than you my contact feel a
little more intentional instead of just
when we're peers they're like yeah like
we're talking now I'm like how's it down
there weirding me out I don't think I
like it I try it on this shoe this shoe
this shoe and this shoe none of them
work the only one that I have left is
this high top it's hard to find shoes
that work because most shoes are not
designed to accommodate heels that go up
three inches
I did get some new shoes though that
make things way more comfortable that
said though I'm pretty annoyed that no
one had all has noticed that I seem
taller hey Keith because none of my
glasses on it I can't really see super
well the shape that came in I was
expecting Zach to come in but like no
that guy's way too tall to be Zach it's
really working
I just wanted to wash my hands and it's
like so much further than I'm used to
someone was like stopping and asking me
like why I was walking so loud this is
how my feet sound when I'm not walking
with the heels and here's how I sound
with the heels can I move it on dating
ants I'm like very interesting guys and
girls who see the shoes want to try it
on and they want to see how they look
and feel in it Ben's actually 510 if it
has
that'll be six one yeah I actually
really like this I want to walk up to my
girlfriend
Toller very strapping yes I'm usually
right here on you
so should I start wearing these all the
time maybe I'm seeing where my yeah
you're definitely taller
so this is me I don't think I could ever
do this but she actually likes it I
honestly don't see that much of a
difference except but I like you the way
you are do you want to try it I feel a
little bit taller do you feel not
significantly do you feel more like
dominant yeah I think a lot of women are
like around my height we're usually
shorter than that so we pull our
dominance from other areas that's a
great point I have a wedding today and
because I'm suddenly taller my date gets
to wear high heels which you would
normally never do around me that's a
plus you have you wear high heels so
happy I like to go on walks on weekends
I did not want to wear those painful ass
shoes today so I'm not sorry
I think these shoes might be good for
life events if you know that you're not
gonna have to wear them for too long
just on days where you have low
self-esteem because as much as I hate to
admit it it does like add like the
spring tear stuff I would definitely
wear these again I would say maybe like
once a week maybe like that I like to
shoot at the most out of all the guys
when I'm at my standing desk it does
help with my posture and makes me ready
to start work I didn't feel like it
helped me in any way a big part of your
height is shown in the shape of your
body tall people just are tall looking
I'm not tall looking it feels cooler to
be taller I did like how I look too
close I don't think there's anything
wrong with it it's something that maybe
I would consider again if the
circumstance was right if I'm dating a
girl and she wants to wear heels but she
can't wear him around me maybe I'll
throw on some boots so we can both be
taller that day I liked having a secret
and see if anyone caught it but it's
really frustrating when literally no one
did height is not as important as we
think it is I'm gonna be happy being a
short guy from now on I realized that
since most people didn't notice all the
confidence is very internal it's kind of
like the Dumbo movie where you had the
feather and it wasn't the better than
made it fly it was him they're short
people that seems taller because of
their personality and they're telling
people that seem smaller because of
their personality I think it's really
just about the way you carry yourself
couple interest here there doesn't
matter as much as the way you live your
life does I am both really appreciative
for the experience but I'm also glad I'm
back to being me
[Music]